hey guys welcome to the Evan and Kaitlyn
podcast the podcast where we take your
cues and turn them into a z' now we turn
them into cues because Evan did the
wrong leak for a QA e K Q and Q
they're gonna bit ly /ek Q and the Q cuz
I I kind of messed that up but if you do
want to ask us questions right now go to
that URL chat yeah there's gonna be
posting a little link there and you guys
can ask us questions and the reason
we're doing that link consider just
reading them from the chat is a few
reasons one it's easier to not have
repeats because our mods are gonna help
us not have repeats in there - you can
upvote the questions so if there's one
you really want to see answered you can
upvote it and I think there was a third
of them but I forgot so hey you know
we're trying to streamline we're trying
to lean into the technology alright so
this is our very this is our very second
live Q&A podcast yeah hopefully we've
learned some lessons from the first one
we aren't gonna be playing a game again
cuz that was too much chaos less chaotic
yet but I think just like some cuny's
will be fine yeah yeah so how are you
guys doing so far it's so funny because
I want to be in like livestream mode
where I'm like oh let's pause for a
second yeah and say hi to everyone in
the chat and reply to everyone but then
that doesn't make for a very good
podcast no I think they're like like
we'll probably cut this we'll cut this
whole thing out I think we'll use that
really bad there's a really bad intro
and then we'll cut there and we'll like
cut just like leave this chunk out and
then we'll get into some serious q and
a's once people have a little bit of
time to submit their q and a's whether
they're free jump trees jump into it
jump into it yeah
is that our Q&A music that's our Q&A
music it's been so long since we did it
alright so number one from wither Prime
did you get any food from Ikea while you
are there you know what normally we do
cuz normally we get like the dollar
hotdogs but they are strangely tasty
there's no they're so good and the chips
so good so good the only reason we
didn't is cuz Houston just recently got
an in and out and so we're now not
always a we're full feels so good I felt
like I was just in California Kim and I
both spent some time living in
California when we were growing up and
like eating it in and out just makes you
feel like you're in California yeah but
you don't have to pay as much money to
live there let's see how do we check off
a question once we do we just like
delete it once we do that I don't know
I'll just start going on the next one do
you ever go back this is from will Bros
Inc do you ever go back and watch your
first videos just to compare them to
current videos we do every now and then
go back I think like we don't do it
intentionally to look at them and
compare but we have gone back a few
times and and yeah from from my
perspective not that I'm biased or
anything but I'm like wow those are
still really good I'm really proud of
them I'm proud of the work that we did
and it's also so crazy thinking about
how much our style has changed and
everything like that yeah yeah we don't
purposely seek it out but sometimes
we'll have to go to a video to like pull
a link from something or like get a clip
that we want to use in a current video
and then we end up getting sucked in and
we're like so weird this is especially
weird thing like the old garage setup oh
yeah especially from like way way back
like even remember how many videos had
rolling shutter and how many comments we
got like yeah we'd spent we had like no
lighting in the garage long and so we
just kept the door open the whole time
but then you know you're reliant on the
Sun lighting which sometimes is super
low and then could go from low just
super bright so we'd have clips that
like like a continuous clip where it
starts out really low and then all of a
sudden were blown out there now we have
time to
different light bulbs in our garage yeah
we keep the door closed oh no we have
even more we have 21 light bulbs since
we added a big one behind us and now we
have two extra tube lights behind us
underneath the thing so now we have 23
individual light sources in our garage
trying to get it as even as possible all
with the same color profile yeah it's a
lot yeah I didn't realize you had the
number in your head like readily
available I counted the other day when
we were filming the alcohol link video
because I wanted to like say in that
video I don't think I did but I wanted
to like say in that video ok we need to
turn some of the light bulbs all off
because there are 20 light bulbs on and
it's like blowing this beautiful like
colored light bulb out and I just like I
counted in advance well you were doing
something else I need to count the light
bulbs ok I wanna say it's gonna be
interesting I saved it and I remembered
it for now yes I'm impressed are there
any projects you filmed but didn't make
into a video I was actually looking for
some Roo wow this is something I'm not
sure if we've talked about yet I wanted
to make a one way valve for the garage
remember that but because we had waiting
for the garage we have our dryer yeah
yeah we have our dryer hooked up to a
vent
stuff the hot air out because that's
what dryers do good explanation and for
ammo for a while there we have wheat rye
thought about heating and cooling our
garage with a little portable rolling
unit and we wanted to hook that heat
exhaust from that up to the same port so
I wanted to try to make like a one-way
valve system so that both those things
could use the same ports and the same
exhaust and I 3d printed something and
it was like a one-way valve
hinge thing it looked so cool it worked
- and there's a spring embedded in it
and we have all this footage of me
prototyping and testing it and
everything but then when we actually
used it it melted
they melt immediately and melted after
the first use in 40 minutes that's the
main thing that I could think of that
we're like I have filmed something it
completely failed where we filmed even
more and it wasn't even just us filming
we had someone else with us what was
that it was I think the reason we didn't
turn it into videos cuz we just didn't
know what it was gonna be but we want to
do something again with 3d printing we
wanted to 3d print and design our own
custom like emojis and letters for
letter boards oh yeah out of like copper
filament and so we were gonna like
design we designed all these custom
emojis that's like half way bills yeah
we we did the copper filament we printed
a bunch of letters right yeah we tested
like five different methods to tumble
them to get their shine design a whole
bunch of really cute like to use like
there's a pineapple a few other ones are
like letters of course but like like and
we had um he's our friend Taylor he at
the time worked for Autodesk and it was
gonna be like a Autodesk I don't know it
was they weren't like sponsoring it I
don't know why he was a part of it I
think he was in town and we were like
hey we're doing this you wanna like film
and yeah I just I don't know it they
went so off the rails because we
couldn't get them things to shine up the
right way and then they left like a
residue on our white letter board and we
were like oh that's not great well I'm
not representing those projects don't
represent our brand right here make film
a fail
make they'll give up but let's say what
we did for each of those so for the AC
problem we basically just like reclosed
that port on the inside we did have a
hole in our wall for about a year and we
just installed a mini split and the mini
split was a much better solution a mini
split oh geez I just I'm a fan of mini
splits now they're so efficient they're
so fast working and everything so in the
end it completely worked
and then for the copper filament maybe
we did for the copper filament we did
this kind of give up why it's not that
we really gave up we um we actually
wanted to expand I thought that the the
scoop of like hey we designed these
letters we printed them and polish them
and that's it we were like where's the
the challenge where's the me where's the
story so we it kind of got lost in an
identity crisis because all of our
videos we want to have a strong punch
too strong a story a strong identity it
just seemed like we weren't doing enough
and then we kind of thought would expand
it with other copper prints but then
it's just uh spending a whole bunch of
copper things yeah polishing them and
then what's the point in that so it's
not really make fail give up it's make
fail if it can't turn into a video then
it kind of gets filed in like our
backlog of things that we can pull from
in the future so that if in the future
we want to do something that involves a
copper print we already part way down
that pathway and we can even pull some
elements of a tumbler for two years
haven't used it since but you know we
need a tumbler we got it we got it
where did y'all put the treadmill
computer I'm not sure if I understand
that question but we can talk about the
treadmill computer yeah so the the
treadmill desks are actually in our
breakfast nook which you know we don't
need two eating areas a lot of people
will turn that into like a little
sitting area or just have it as like a
breakfast nook that they never eat in
ours formerly it was just like a place
where we kept like Amazon packages that
we needed to deal with and like it was
one of the junk room it was one of the
many junk rooms so that's where they are
well I think that also there might be
another thing the the computer is
actually a Raspberry Pi for oh not what
the question is so it's a really really
tiny computer but we also have a link so
that we can access our big powerful like
I 9 16 gigabyte RAM computers over here
that's in
our office which is where we're at now
so we can use the power of those
computers remotely if we want to yeah
okay let's see what's your dream project
that you would like to make slash do at
some point I think one thing this isn't
really one project it's kind of a series
but eventually I mean we're already kind
of growing out of this house in terms of
what we need for workshop space and what
we new need for like office / studio
space and so I think it'd be really fun
to get like a fixer-upper type house and
just redo a ton of it yeah like the
details there it's it's a little bit
flexible we could buy a house that has
good bones and build a big workshop we
could buy a workshop and add a house to
the side of it I'm not fully sure it's
kind of ordered going or we just buy a
plot of land and like build the whole
for that thing from scratch but that
just seems like so much work and so many
decisions but we do need like more space
because our house is the filming area
and Chris actually clarified I was
basically asking what room it was in you
all seem to be running out of one one
question we've seen in like our social
areas where you guys leave comments and
feedback is like what happened to that
junk over here what happened that junk
over here where'd you move that junk so
constantly being moved we still have it
somewhere I will say I will say two
things one we accumulate stuff so much
faster now than we used to we used to be
pretty but good about keeping mom there
there is a point where we really speak
stuff input to our life and it's been
going down the railing down I wish we
acquire new stuff has been reduced
dramatically starting the business
getting all the tools that we needed to
do stuff and then at the same time every
week we're like making things so we're
always bringing like a new piece of
furniture or like decor item or art or
whatever every single week into the
house and so it just builds up really
fast but we've gone from three
completely just filled with stuff areas
which was the garage the breakfast nook
the guest room and now it's only one
yeah and so one gets shuffled depending
on what room were working in so yeah so
when we cleared out the garage all of
that junk that we didn't have time to
deal with moved into the breakfast nook
when we turned the breakfast nook into
the oh no and the guest room when we
redid the guest room all of it moved to
the breakfast move to the breakfast nook
and then when we did the gaming
treadmill suite and we had just recently
completed just reading a strim project
and I felt like such a failure like
putting a stuff back in it was so sad
but even though like I knew we would
have to because you got to put it
somewhere we're still trying to like
deal with it you know and like we take
stuff to Goodwill and get things to
friends and family and stuff like that
but so do you have any plans for more
home improvement type projects coming up
soon a spider trap man we have a patio
project coming out soon we're actually
gonna start that probably this week
because the weather is a lot nicer now
than it will be the the video is gonna
be like late January but that's when
it's super cold in Texas you know like
40 and and we finish we want to apply to
the back patio requires a certain
temperature so it's kind of like the
clock is ticking if we don't do this
project soon yeah we're just gonna have
to wait months and we already have the
sponsor lined up and we're already
committed so so we have to do like we
have to do it now backyard patio kind of
makeover we're gonna have some little
projects added onto I think it might be
a small separate video but we're gonna
kind of like do a big makeover and a
little side DIY that complement each
other yeah yeah so that's the next one
but we are kind of running out of like
not running out I mean we could make
over a room just to make it over but
we're kind of running out of things that
like practically make sense you know
just cuz we've done a lot of the rooms
in this house but also there aren't many
rooms in the house that need to be
renovated I mean we might redo our guest
bathroom that I'm pointing to over there
yeah unnecessarily yeah there's a few
like like smaller
and there's some stuff like we get a lot
of comments like oh you guys should
repaint your kitchen cabinets cuz
they're kind of like a orangie wood and
I'm like yeah that'd be nice
if someone else did
there's a lot of time invested for like
not that much video time because cuz we
just time-lapse like all the paintings
yeah that interesting but yeah well you
know we'll kind of play it play it by
air in terms of like more home
renovation things or eventually we'll
just end up moving cuz we need more
space what's your most disappointing
build or project this does never came
out do you want the way you wanted it to
from mil Tron 11 I don't think that
there was anything where I'm like um no
I mean we've had moments of that worse
we did something and it really didn't
look nice but usually we just redo it um
I feel like there oh no no no no no no I
have to the resin planets for mobile
that wasn't a big disappointment I think
that they turned out really cool it just
wasn't exactly what we expected so I
think it was a expectation versus
reality type moment there and we're like
this sounds kind of fun to do let's just
try it so in terms of the video I'm not
disappointed I think the video turned
out well but the project wasn't exactly
what I expected one other thing oh this
is probably the biggest the resin and
concrete there are moments Roma wow this
looks so cool this is exactly what I
wanted find a way to make them work like
combination of materials work we do seem
to be more patient we just need to do it
and let them dry in between layers go I
don't know all we did is we just mixed
things but all we did I'm pretty sure we
just mixed this back just in case y'all
don't know what video we're talking
about it's we cut potatoes to make them
look like faceted we vacuum-formed them
to make molds and
in those molds we did different
combinations of white concrete and resin
and we wanted to make like little rocky
gem looking things I didn't realize that
we never like let one dry before doing
the other I'm doubting now because I'm I
think that we didn't know that we wanted
I know and they had so much potential we
still have them they're just like we
have the ones that we never remove the
plastic from because it basically fused
to the plastic you know I think that we
could probably do that better now thank
we good people had suggestions of like
we in the water cup so it doesn't
overheat oh yeah some of it was using to
the plastic we could also go with a
silicone which is higher temperature I
know it's just so much easier to do the
vacuum for molds I think that we we have
maybe two different ideas we have vacuum
fold molt by vacuum-formed molds which I
want to do again because those were just
really fun really satisfying really fast
yeah so I feel like there's potential
there to do something with that and then
I think that there's mixing resin and
concrete and I think that we can kind of
split that into two different videos we
don't necessarily need to do that exact
combo again yeah yeah yeah so something
yeah that is one if there's one new
skill you could learn and share it on
enk what would it be by the britain DC I
think it'd be cool to learn how to like
turn stuff on a lathe mostly cuz there's
a lot of really cool resin stuff you can
on a lathe so I think that would be cool
it also just seems beef like satisfying
yeah Bob did a lamp the other day Bob
from I like to make stuff that a lamp
with resin and you turned it on the
lathe to finish it up yeah I just think
I don't know some potential there
although there aren't that many round
long objects you can like there could be
like a bowl it could be a ring it could
be like a wand I want to learn Forge and
more and metalworking like I just I
don't know uh you guys might have seen
the collaboration we did with Alex deal
but there's another thing that we didn't
really get to make a video about we went
to Lincoln through an event of spring
makes spring make and ATS
make they had a knife making class and I
made a little crescent moon knife but
it's like it's really cute it's so cool
so we could like order some laser cut a
tool steel that we can use for blades so
we don't need to do that hard part in
house and we could just you know Forge
it quench it add an edge to it make some
resin or wood handles I think that'd be
really really cool I definitely want to
and I can turn the handles on the lathe
no you can't you could you could you
could and then it just be a cylindrical
thing and then yeah you could drill it
and we're gonna stick the tent hang in
there yeah yeah you could maybe you have
some metal elements like you could also
add some brass brass elements to it and
everything that actually be kind of cool
yeah I think the thing with me in
blacksmithing is I got spoiled on the
power hammer it's just so fast but the
good thing about getting the shape cut
out on the laser jet and then forging it
a little bit it's all you need to do is
just bring the tip in a little bit and
then beat it up to give the cool texture
and then like your that isn't like
starting with like a chunk of steel and
yeah and trying to draw it out and shape
the whole thing that's just a lot of
work yeah that's true but in terms of
what we want to show our skills
developing bob was talking about
something very similar on the making it
podcast and he was talking about like
his goals in general with the channel
and i think that one thing that I really
want to do it's a vision that had in my
head since I was like 4 or something
maybe not for I'm exaggerating but I
always wanted to have a shop have all of
the skills have all of the tools to make
anything a penny time out of any
material and just realize the visions
that we have in our head and I think
that's eventually where we want to get
whether the best way to get there is 3d
printing or CNC or welding or leather
working or whatever it is I basically
want to level up our skills too
a good enough level at everything yeah
suddenly can just do anything yeah I
don't I don't like disagree with that I
think it's a cool goal but long-term my
issue is that a lot of those things
require full sets of equipment that's
when we get our giant workshop in the
future yeah yeah
well I like the scope of our future
workshop keeps on increasing it's gonna
be bigger than our house it's gonna be
bigger than our house we need more
workshops based in-house space one one
dream thing that we have for the future
space is to have a like really clean
white backdrop white like workbench or
something like that like really like
clean aesthetically pleasing set so that
we can do our art there so we can do
photo shoots there and I think it'd be
kind of cool to livestream some crafts
what's that on there gaming live
streaming and then our workshop
livestream thing the main thing is
having room to have multiple sets yeah I
think the white is good for some stuff
but I don't want to like just film most
videos in there I like a little bit more
stuff going on yeah like I like having
like doodads and things we've made in
the background like our minecraft
pickaxe so we can have like a cozy
styled set we can have our pure white
set and then we're gonna have our
workshop set so we have three sets at
least yeah the reason I have a big
warehouse where you just have multiple
sets and then we have like workshop over
there metal shop I really would shop
over here metal shop over there
we just wanted since then and and
everything has lights always set up and
we can just walk into an area boom all
the lights are all good the color
balance is all perfect and we can just
not worry about any of that and just
film really good videos yeah cuz right
now it's um anytime we're switching what
kind of project we're doing we often
have to do like a big game of Tetris in
the shop if we need to like for
switching from like a woodworking
project to a CNC project like everything
else to get switched around so it would
be nice yeah someone someone noted in in
the chat you guys still have room in
your garage and I'm not sure if you're
being sarcastic or not cuz it's like
really maybe we just do a really good
job at hiding how bad it is because it's
workable it's we just shuffle things
yeah yeah say we have a rotating pile of
stuff that we just kind of move out of
the way the set and storage cabinets on
one side and then the other side is just
like Tetris
we have everything's on wheels and we
just like roll things in and out but
there's not room to bring in more things
no bringing in more things would mean
like we lose the space we need to like
take one thing out and put the other
thing back in one day all right let's
take a little break to to say hi to
people a little bit looking on the chat
and also I think our new subscribers
Petey chemist thanks for two months sub
awesome awesome
mr. back six months now you get the
fancy supervisor with the awesome and
then Jeff fours Jax whoops thank you for
the three month Risa that's awesome any
plans to do any meet and greets in the
future hmm we've done like a cup like
one but we thought if you like
everything about it every place that we
go to like a big event we do meet and
greet people and I think that there's
often like like pre-planned mean a group
meeting yes like it's interesting I just
have the feeling that if we did one in
Houston like I have the fear that like
no one shows up and like you have to
like pick a place to do it and like pre
talk to the people there just in case a
lot of people do Sh it's hard to get
like a number account if too many people
show up then that's a health and safety
risks and if yeah few people show up
that's I think I'm traumatized by our
like West Elm story oh we were out like
no no subs back then let's go start like
no one's gonna show so yeah
we've done meet-and-greets like when
it's attached to something else yeah
yeah but I mean that doesn't mean that
we won't do it maybe I'll get over my
fear that no how one thing we definitely
want to do is I really hope that there's
another big conference in the u.s. that
a lot of people are coming together at
where we can kind of like me like if
Maker Faire comes back like if Maker
Faire comes back I just I'm so sad that
Maker Faires
no more yeah so we'll see yeah I just
like randomly looked up at the chat and
I see TJ saying oh no Kaitlyn's a pirate
oh my god oh so funny yeah but maybe
like if we put out some feelers and we
could get an idea for how many people
would come it would make it a little bit
easier to to plan and like see you know
we've never like done we're definitely
definitely out opposed to it and we have
we want to do something like that in the
future so yes yeah okay so what are some
of your favorite shows and film was what
genres do you enjoy it by tell Elektra
we watch a lot of YouTube but I guess in
terms of non youtube I think that's a
good knowledge like it's it's
interesting let's acknowledge the
YouTube that we watch and kind of talk
about some of the genres and swish we
watch more like kind of general
entertainment type stuff like kind of
more mainstream stuff honestly on
YouTube than maker specific stuff
although there are a few channels where
that kind of overlaps yeah so we watch a
lot of bone Appetit watch a lot of bone
Appetit we love Brad we love Claire we
look so many other people there and
there's even new series that we found
out like approach like I think that they
need to work on their marketing and
their titles and thumbnails because we
just randomly cooked on the bone update
video mystery she gets kidnapped been
taken to an ostrich farm and there's
like clues and there's like intrigue in
there the title is just like probe chef
learns how to cook ostrich eggs videos
so much more than that
yeah so we watched a lot of bone cavity
we watched simply no logical jenna
Marbles try guys
Sophia Nygaard so yeah again a lot of
like mainstream stuff but we also we
watch a lot of Bobbie Duke William
Osmond those are probably the ones that
are like maker and entertainment yeah
yeah because I think it's like I think
that YouTube can be shows in films you
know cuz yeah maybe not films
I mean potential it shows cuz I a lot of
the stuff we watch is like like we're
still watching some bone Appetit like
Thanksgiving making perfect mmm and
every episodes like 40 minutes long
that's like a TV episode even our our
average video link these days is like 25
minutes yeah so I feel like it like
counts as a as a show oddly and in terms
of how do you divide it recites a
traditional media yeah traditional media
like stuff now Netflix is a strange mix
cuz is Netflix traditional or is Netflix
like in the zone third category is
traditional media at this point yeah
same with like Amazons I think so
original programming stuff cuz it's all
none of its like independent creators if
it's not independent creators that kind
of consider it traditional media if it's
like tied to big companies or big
budgets and restrictions and stuff like
that so we we don't have cable we have
my mom's Netflix account so it's some
stuff on Netflix like we watched like
stranger things
we watched the new queer I it was like I
don't know there's not too much we watch
up that's not on YouTube oh really we
just we have a strong adversan to
wasting our time we don't have like we
only want to watch like sure bet type
things it's so funny every now and then
I'll glance up at the chat and I just
see a wave of buttons right anyone
joining and wondering why everyone's
spamming butts it's because um so
usually we use our twitch for streaming
games and it's a lot of like Minecraft
and stuff and there's lots of talk about
like oh minecraft channels are gonna get
like slammed by cop-out Copa something
and so it's like well we got to make it
not kid-friendly like inappropriate
things but we don't want to make it like
age-restricted
so we just decided that periodically
everyone needs to yell butts and so
new people are wondering that's Lex
let's see
do you prefer to fix things that aren't
working or make new ones by foxy mara I
think probably make new things is more
fun at least for me I prefer to make to
make new things just cuz it's more open
and what you want to do and I do think
sometimes it's cool to take a thing and
modify it in a new way that's not
necessarily like fixing something though
but like the IKEA stuff or when we went
antique shopping and poured marble on
the like old trays it's kind of like
taking a thing and modifying it and even
honestly in our projects like we have a
project coming up all right I guess
we've done this in past projects to
where we'll take something kind of
already partly made like we use butcher
block in every desk video and so like
we'll take that and upgrade it oh hello
supervisor hi see the supervisor wants
to hang out um but I think we like
making new stuff more than fixing hi
hello Evans my choirs in the way come on
we'll see if those supervisor will bless
us with her presence um what about you
do you feel the same way or do you like
I mean you're probably better at fixing
things
I think these scooch in she'll come she
doesn't want to go in front of oh here
she goes hey I like making new things I
like trying to come up with my own
solution I like trying to come up with
my own
I love inventing I love coming up with
neat clever little things so yeah I am
Evans mom stopped by just a little bit
before we started doing the podcast and
I was telling her about how we have a
blessed command the supervisor shows up
bless us with her presence and she was
like wow yes he or she is very hard to
see you exposed our green screen no
you're gonna see all of the various
computers we have one tiny hidden one he
another one here another one there
another one there another one there yes
hello hello I'm supervising okay so what
are the best starting tools for wood
work I think we've answered that a few
times
I think so too similar questions by Nia
twins and then again Abby Lane 64 which
is that oh that's a good budget
nevermind so we'll get to that one
separate yeah in terms of um tools I
think just get what you need for a
project because if you try to guess what
you're gonna need and you just buy a
bunch of tools they might just end up
sitting there not getting used or you
might later on you know six months from
now and you finally use it you might
know more and realize oh I wish I would
have gotten the miter saw that you know
has a bigger blade because it's not that
much more extensive and I could do so
many more things so I think like don't
don't buy more than you need it by per
project yeah now it also depends on what
types of projects you're going after
some people the best tool might just be
a 3d printer and you just get into 3d
printing and that's one tool that like
to get into 3d printing all you need is
a 3d printer and you can just 3d print
as much as you want if you're doing
woodworking that's a whole another set
of tools if you're doing leather working
that's a whole other set of tools and
depending on the space that you have and
why you're making would recommend
different materials if you have a very
small space and you just want to make
just to make maybe leather working might
be a good thing for you because it's
really small all the tools are small
it's a very small thing and you can just
put it away really easily it's
relatively cheap I think so we're not
the best to give suggestions there but I
just but I think the general rule of
like pick a project that you're excited
about and just buy what you need for
that and the excitement is the most
important thing because then you'll do
it falling through and finishing the
project is the most important part
because then you might want to do
another one then you might want to do
another one you get like pulled in and
it becomes more meaningful and you get
a lot of enjoyment because a lot of this
is if you're good at things it's more
enjoyable
I don't know and doing things again and
again and doing things that you're more
excited about makes it more fun yeah see
what would you suggest as a good budget
slash materials tools to get started
okay so that one's kind of similar again
like I don't really it's hard to say
what a good budget would be because it
all depends on the project like we just
try to when we're buying tools we read a
lot of reviews and if it's something
that we foresee ourselves using for a
lot of different things we tend to not
go with the very cheapest option because
we've made the mistake of going with the
cheapest option and then we have to
upgrade like less than a year later and
that's always kind of painful so I
wouldn't set like a specific budget but
I try to get stuff it's like striking
that balance between like you don't want
to go out and buy Festool everything and
like ruin you know your entire savings
but you also don't want to buy stuff
that you're gonna have to replace
immediately so yeah so are you gonna
make more soap possibly yeah I want to
that's Fran it was really fun knife
roxas yeah yeah I would like to do more
soap stuff we kind of like going
tangents and then we get distracted by
other things I still want to do candle
making to like I think that'd be fun oh
we went down this rabbit hole up do you
guys know the carved candles oh yeah you
like dip them in multiple layers and
then carve them and we're like oh maybe
we'll try that that sounds fun and easy
we watched a video oh my gosh it's so
complicated it's it's so skilled you
need so many vats of vats and also you
have to the wax has to be the right
temperature sometimes you need to cool
it sometimes you need to warm it you
have to work really quickly so then it
doesn't get too cold and brittle and it
breaks and shatters and it's just like
whoa but it did look incredibly
satisfying it's definitely an oddly
satisfying thing yeah when you were
selling your deer heads etc how did you
decide on a price I decided to price an
item to sell to the average person
okay and that's by wow girl 93 so that's
referring to not everyone may know this
but we used to sell products so we
started like on Etsy and then we started
selling to West Aleman like a wholesale
basis and we would do like pop-up shops
and stuff and the way that we decided to
price our things is we looked at what
similar items were going for on the
various platforms like at West Elm you
know when we were gonna start doing
pop-up shops there we said like hey
what's a good price point to aim for
like we talked to the people in the
store and they said oh four pop-up shops
keep it under 100 because you know under
100 is still kind of an impulse buy if
you go over 100 people won't just buy it
on the spot and so we then worked
backwards and figured out how we could
make the things we want to make like
what materials and processes we needed
to use to keep it under hundred so we
kind of worked backwards in that way but
you can also just like if you already
have something specific in mind you know
exactly how you want to do it or you
already have like a stock of it you can
just look at prices of similar things
you know to stay competitive and I think
that we're gonna shout out our friends
podcast here May for profit I'm not sure
what episode them it might be but they
kind of go into how to price products
for sale and they kind of spend a whole
podcast talking about that and they yes
they have some experience I'm like a
pricing price good yeah guide like a
worksheet kind of thing - yeah so it
might be patrons only I'm not sure but
yeah made for profit great podcast if
you want to learn like the business side
of stuff so why and when did you first
start using resin buy Khaleesi
we we are first resin project um I guess
the wine the one is kind of tied so you
know people have been doing like River
tables for a while and we had this idea
that we wanted to do a geode table with
resin because we hadn't seen anyone do
it and we never used resin before and it
was kind of ambitious and so we're like
okay well we really want to do this
project how like we need to start
getting
and start practicing with so we did a
couple small projects so interesting cuz
I'm not sure if we ever talked about
that the geode table was the impetus
between behind all of the resin yes it's
not like we started up like with the
resin coasters and the resin slice and
then went to the geode it wasn't we
didn't go in that order we thought of
the last one first and then built these
building blocks to get us to the
confidence to do that yeah yeah so we
did two resin projects before the geode
table just so that we could practice
with resin
because we had never used it before and
then I'm so glad we did oh it would have
been such a big mistake to go straight
to the resin geode also I think honestly
I think we would have been okay we might
have been okay but we would have been so
much more panicking yeah it would have
been stressful oh actually no we
wouldn't have been okay
by the time we did the geode slices we
were fine but if we didn't do that
initial practice video where we just
poured random stuff into coaster molds
cuz those all looks pretty bad they
looked into the head they like looking
back they're pretty bad I tried to do a
geode it is not like you know she
checked in on us making sure that we
were doing the podcast correctly yes and
she can move on now yes mm-hmm
let's see so what were your first jobs
[Music]
Liam Molony I think that we've talked
about that some in the press we can
touch on it briefly I was an engineer I
was a graphic designer and they were a
good job they're fun job they're fun
jobs but I think you know we've talked
about this potentially a little more in
the past but I'll just you know as well
go into it a little bit more we just
really wanted to be together and we
wanted more time together and we
couldn't really find jobs that were
alike it would become would it be kind
of weird if we worked in the same office
would that be cooler that'd be weird
it'd be cooler than not working in the
same office yeah then like like if I saw
you in the hallway could I give you a
hug would that be like acceptable in a
workplace I feel like people if they
didn't know we were married
it might be weird like to co-workers
hugging or like we're like when we sit
together at lunch if I like put my arm
around you or something like that then
like think that I'm harassing you or
something but but anyways they're there
they're good jobs but this this again I
think is potentially like one of the
best possible scenarios for both of us
we both like making stuff we both like
being creative we both like documenting
the process of creating and we both love
sharing it and that's all of what we do
and I think would be hard to combine all
of those in the other way than what
we're doing right now yeah I mean we
kind of had tried just in hobby form
doing a blog which is similar but what
we've realized even though editing a
video takes so much longer than doing a
blog like taking photos of every step
and writing seems so much more tedious
and video editing is more fun it's so
much easier to like add humor and stuff
so I think it suits us better we just
didn't know it at the time yeah so Calum
this is a good question for you when
editing what is something you focus on
most would it be the lighting colouring
the sounds the composition I think it's
something else
LTL toy ever yeah yeah it's actually
none of those things really I focus on
pacing so things like lighting colouring
sound we've put all lasts well actually
they're kind of first in a way oh yeah
during the filming yeah like those are
all we try to get those as good as we
can during the filming so that I don't
have to spend time editing the color and
the sound and stuff like that because I
used to spend so much time getting it
right especially like like I said back
and we're using the Sun for our light so
much time post-processing and we don't
really worry about like composition too
much like things are gonna be framed the
way that they're framed so most of my
time is spent on the pace and making
sure like it's a good balance of faster
paced parts with slower paced parts so
your
so you have like a chance to breathe and
going back and forth between like when
we're in montage mode or if we're
filming something in more of a like
real-time style like when we do resin
pores and we just have the camera
rolling the whole time so that's kind of
related to a question we get sometimes
about like do you aim for your videos to
be a certain length and we don't I just
aim for a certain pace so that like I
don't get bored watching any scene but I
also don't feel like it moved too fast
and I need to go back because I missed
something so it's like trying to balance
those two things I think that yeah the
main focus yeah unlike Galen said we did
spend oh there's a there's a time where
we are going through like buying a new
camera and we're okay let's buy two new
cameras let's get this all set up we
spent days researching what cameras to
buy and then we spent days going back
and forth from the garage to the
computer where we would change like you
know would set up the lighting would do
the color balance on one camera and
color balance in another camera make
sure that they the color profiles
matched because we're using one
Panasonic and one Canon and we want to
make sure like the the temperatures the
hue all of that looked the same for both
cameras so we spent a whole bunch of
time fixing that once yeah then we don't
have to do it again yeah every single
video especially cuz like 98% of our
filming is all done in that one garage
yeah so if we can get the lights
constant and the color balance constant
then we're good we're still trying to
work on the audio the audio is still a
little bit of a thing that we're in the
process of working on because we have
kind of very specific requirements we
want yeah I don't want to I won't get
into all of the technical details but
you have to people then just one person
like you're more limited in your options
you're more little bit nervous if you
don't want to be like syncing multiple
audio tracks yeah we didn't we don't
wanna do that we just want everything on
a mono already pre-mixed we just go
let's see you can only have one tool for
the rest of forever what would you
choose from the Briton do you see I
think I would possibly go like one tool
I'd say a 3d printer and then out sheet
and then I'd make all the other tools
with it 3d printed table saw 3d printed
drill 3d printed six three van a table
saw that'd be kind of Awesome and so
scary for the blade not got 3d printed
you can get consumables a blade as a
consumable okay I guess I guess that
works I don't know it was a pretty good
answer I don't really have a good answer
yeah yeah it makes tools your tool would
be a camera oh yeah and then and Adobe
Premiere would play with dirt in the
backyard and build stuff I don't know
what would become would become a ancient
technology technology because primitive
technology the only camera he has the
only tool he has as a camera and then he
builds the restless' tools using an
awesome channel like primitive
technology but with a 3d printer and
like everything is like wrong let's see
have you ever thought if you ever
considered doing challenge videos or you
both go off and do your own things on
secret and then see which is best Archie
we have actually done that once where we
kind of did it secretively on
Thanksgiving Day and launched it watch
it and launched it like I think the day
after Thanksgiving cuz we're like we
needed Thanksgiving special videos and
so we made mashed potato launches and we
kind of competed and we could only use
like scrap material we had I feel like
we could film something like that better
now but also I think that the one big
problem is we would almost need a camera
person yeah that's that's the issues we
need we would need like a camera person
because the way the style of our filming
works is a lot of its us interacting
together and like when we have moving
cameras it's one of us filming the other
person and I think it'd be hard to do
that and not see what the other person's
making you know we can put up like a
wall between us and have a camera person
but also a lot of what we have fun doing
while we're making is interacting
together it's like I love like like
messing with me our energy is combined
and they're better I think that one
thing that both of us kind of learned
when we are vlogging is it's hard to
like have the same energy when it's just
you oh you mean when we did like little
tests for fun vlogs but on our own yeah
you know a third one that never came out
I'm still in the beams here but you even
filled one more like I got a secret vlog
and just like warm up and figure out how
to vlog basically see if we wanted to do
vlogs cuz we've gotten some requests
yeah and there's a portion of it it was
just you and it's so hard to film by
myself I'm just not used to it yeah
maybe it's just something we need to
practice more maybe we just need to try
more in the future but we kind of do so
instead of doing like competitions where
it's totally secret we often will add
small competitive elements where we each
do our own version of the same thing so
like for example the antique tray with
the marble resin pour or like the resin
planets you know we would each have our
own version of it
you know we can kind of see like whose
is best so it's not like a secret
necessarily but we have like some semi
competitive elements yeah okay so I
think we already got that one yeah who
would you most like to collaborate with
I think that we have theorized and kind
of brought it up very nebulous Leah but
Bobbie Duke yeah I think it'd be super
fun to collab with Bobbie he's probably
we are two most requested collabs are
Bobbie Duke and simply illogical we're
friends with Bobby
christine does not know who we are so
yeah it's a great like meet Christine
and Ben at like VidCon or something like
that and get to know them and establish
a relationship that's how we'd like to
do collaborations generally it's like we
don't really collab with people that we
don't know already
like just cuz like because then the
rapport isn't there and I want to know
we don't really feel unnatural yeah yeah
so I think that we've we've met and hung
out with Bobby like two to three times
and he was open to maybe doing a collab
but at the same time there's a lot of
like logistics that go into collab yeah
like we still need to figure out and
he's really busy he's off in California
right now yeah doing a whole bunch of we
haven't like brand specific ideas to him
yet I just we just think it'd be super
fun yes so is this an awesome person
yeah he's awesome dude when are you
gonna get a cat cam I'd be shooting back
soon
yeah we do want one I was like where do
we put it and what I mean like we're on
screen do we put it so it it doesn't
block other stuff we're already blocking
a lot like do we just block replace our
faces with but also like she's on my lap
so it wouldn't be like a green screen in
the background it just be like a square
that's like my belly and her head maybe
we need to only know maybe Kalin's we do
a project where we build a green screen
cat bed but that's relying on her using
the thing that we make you know she's
got hop in my lap yeah
it's not likely to work because I'm warm
and toasty and I give her pets yeah
nothing can compete with that okay Kayla
we turned you into a green-screen
will you stream you have green pants on
and a green shirt that's right here just
on the belly I don't know you can just
get green tights pull it up over your
shirt
super stylish and dreams get any other
green screen the chair - yes your green
screen blanket Oh a green blanket a
green blanket actually work and she
would love it should love it
should she wouldn't like tights do we
prefers pants if you're not in pants
she's a little bit more hesitant about
being in your house you're like look at
you and go like she's like this is okay
but I would like you to put on pants
like she's like oh look at you and you
know what she is thinking yeah she like
put her paws on your lap and kind of
like stand up and she's like you're in
shorts are like you're in lightnings no
I don't know no I don't know do friends
and family always ask you to make them
things and is it hard when you have to
say you know from beltron 11 people
don't actually super often I think
that's because we never set a precedent
yeah it's like if we did it for one
family member or a friend then a lot
more would potentially things mostly
like 3d printed stuff mhm
cuz that's a little bit more passive so
like oh you need knob a knob for the
pool cover because they don't make that
anymore like well 3d print your pool
cover I think that there's another
aspect to it also and I think that we've
explained it enough to our friends and
family so that they know and understand
what goes into making a good YouTube
video because it all starts with the
idea like that's the like so much of an
important part of the video and also
will it make for a good thumbnail will
it make for a good title because
clickability is such a huge part of
youtube if you can't get a good title or
thumbnail then it's not gonna do that
well yeah and like you know I think that
initially like we might have got some
requests to fix a bathroom sink like the
drain or something there we're
definitely request we got in the
beginning like oh do you want to fix our
sink cuz it's not working you can make a
youtube video out of it we're like I
don't think
we have to if we made a resin sink
that's okay like we had a
glow-in-the-dark resin sink yeah
we won't like a couple requests like we
did like the wine rack for my parents
oh yeah a couple things where we were
like oh that would be big enough for ya
or like we said if it's something like
little and quick we can do but I think
our parents and our families also know I
mean they they like see how busy we are
with stuff and they know like you know
they can put in a request but it may not
happen for a really long time
forever so yeah so no that's not much of
an issue just because we never let it
get there will you ever go to rent
studio studio place for a workshop are
filming studio by Evander's attack I
would prefer not to just cause like I
don't want to deal with renting a place
and also I like having it be at home cuz
especially with things like take like a
resin port for example it takes 30
minutes to you know do a big pour and
then it's got a cure for overnight but
also you might need to do a second layer
within two hours and then you might also
need to peel a tape right you can't
really easily do like it's not like you
could do that and then start work on
your woodworking project that creates a
lot of sand dust or that will get in the
resin so it's like with with the
infinity table as an example we thought
that we are done we did a poor it looked
fine and we left to go we went inside to
go eat and right before we started
eating I just popped out into the garage
to check things and it was warping and
everything was wrong and and looks like
what if we had have gone to like you
know if we have a studio away from our
home we like finished for the day we
poured the alcohol ink or the resident
and we left thinking there's all K and
then it all went wrong like 20 minutes
later would have been able to fix it but
it would have put us it would have
delayed us by like 24 hours instead of
20 minutes um so yeah so we just like
having our workshop be at our house so I
see us keeping that yeah and potentially
some people have you know who
face similar issues to us they're like I
really like having my workshop away from
my home because it creates a separation
and I think there is something to be
said for that
but with the amount of stuff we're doing
and trying to fit into our day
optimization is number one and and yeah
we know like work-life balance isn't
really a thing right now
far away wouldn't really help us have
better work/life balance it would just
mean we'd be driving more yeah but I
also think like we I feel like if we got
to a place timewise where we could have
more work-life balance I think we would
like we we like having a you know more
free time and stuff I don't think we
would like fill it up with work
unnecessarily of course as I'm saying
that I think a lot of people would look
at what we do and say we've already
filled it up unnecessarily but at the
same time I mean friends and family have
asked us about like you know and I think
that a lot of people have maybe
wondering how we addressed why we
started the gaming channel when we
already had a successful making chain
the podcast and the podcast another
thing into the mix I think we're just
looking long long long term I mean you
see a lot of other youtubers and the
things that they're going through and no
person has really had a full career has
a youtuber yet yeah not really not in
the same sense of like traditional
careers where there's like a set path
there's you know the starting position
there's where you work your way up you
retire but for YouTube it's a different
thing and channels can't stay static
forever you know you can't have one
channel that does the same thing for 30
years I mean maybe you could if it's a
really good premise that has a lot of
growth and progress built into it but
we're just thinking long long term and
that's that's what guides a lot of our
decisions not like a short-term reason
but the long-term reasons yeah and I'm
not sure if that really answered the
question what was the question
dad I think you made up I think you had
question which is why we started the
gaming channel and podcast I think more
specifically is gaming is something that
we used to do a lot together before we
started the channel and it was one of
the things that we had to stop doing
like some things we didn't mind giving
up like like watching more shows than we
do now it was like a sign but we really
wanted to start gaming again but we knew
ourselves and knew if we weren't somehow
making content out of it that it would
be hard to like take time away from the
main channel but if we could like trick
ourselves into thinking it was work then
then we'd play and so we just started
streaming on Twitch randomly about a
year ago it was like last December yeah
maybe January and I think that I was
like I was slowly convinced Caitlyn that
we should do this yeah yeah but and so
it was like a way to even that was
adding more work it also kind of gives
us more sanity because now a few times a
week we get to take like a couple hour
break and play video games it's so much
fun yeah so and kind of similar the
podcast is similar it's like it's
technically more work but it also helps
us take a break and just sit and chat
and hang out so yeah pink stormtrooper
rod up jennamarbles as someone who's
been doing it for a long time and it's
still growing really small jenna Marbles
is a huge inspiration to us yeah she's
like it's like her continents still it's
like so wholesome she's still just like
such a genuine person and you can tell
that she's still just really enjoys
doing what she does and staying true to
herself and not letting like the the
machine that is what we operate in like
dictate what she should do whenever yeah
I also like that and this is just cuz
this is like what I would like to do but
I think it's cool that she hasn't over
expanded not that there's anything wrong
with like building teams and stuff like
that and like you know we have you know
our editors that help us and you know on
the gaming channel in the gaming channel
and things like that but I think like
you know one of the reasons that we
started YouTube is to work together like
the two of us
and you know be able to be creative and
make things and stuff like that and you
know we always had the worry that if we
had to expand the team too much then we
just spend time managing people or like
we turn our cool like we're just working
you know down the hall in our house in
our PJs to like an office scenario we
don't really want to feel like we're
working in an office and flexibilities
is so important and so like we we want
to try to stay pretty small team wise
and so it's cool for me to like look at
Jenna and see that like okay she has you
know she has like roam her manager and
like her mom helps out with the podcast
yeah you know yeah each other and stuff
like that but I just I think it's cool
wow yolo snail coming into ten months
look at that explosion I don't know
that's got to be one of our longest yeah
that's awesome well thank you the others
now yeah longtime supporter that's
awesome thank you pink storm trooper
thanks for the hundred bits and signed
your in thanks for the hundred bits woot
also sorry anyone whose names we've been
mispronouncing we we try but we also
don't want to spend too long stumbling
over it so we just kind of look at it
get a general impression and just give
it a shot so Kailyn this is a really
interesting question what are your goals
for 2020 both on your channel and
projects by the DNC 2020 goals um so one
is kind of related to what we were
talking about it is we're trying to
establish a little bit more work/life
balance
um like if we could stop working after
dinner in the evenings that'd be cool
mm-hmm you know or like maybe we
continue work after dinner but we take
weekends off or something I don't know
right now it's like biggest goal is to
pull back on how much we work
yeah just cuz like right now it's it's
you know we don't take off weekends we
work every day of the week and we work
until we go to bed basically like will
take occasional small breaks to like go
on
walk or like you know like when Shane
Dawson comes out with a new series we're
gonna watch it you know things like that
we'll take little breaks here and there
um but that's probably our biggest goal
for 2020 yeah and I think that one
potential way we might be doing that is
by throwing more buffer weeks in there
it's painful it's painful for us I know
that you guys don't really like that
either
but it's it's long term really healthy
yes we started doing buffer weeks like
the second half of this year and it's
helped us not go more crazy than we did
oh my gosh like even like this month
that we're coming out of like October
November we're insane yeah the fourth of
December a few days ago that marked like
the end of this month and a half long
crazy period where we were just pretty
stressed and I think that there are a
few times where I just got like so
stressed and I got kind of frustrated
when things weren't going right it's
like when everything was going right
things were still good but if something
tripped us up I would like I not kind of
get a little bit I'd get a little bit
rayji I call it like it will rage it I
just like it like when you make noises
like it's not that bad I mean we're
still doing the stuff that we like but
the the stress and the deadlines and
everything when you have zero days spare
when you schedule out every single day
and you have no spare days and you slip
a day then you're like what how are we
gonna do this are we gonna stay up late
are we gonna give up even more of our
non-existent personal time it's just
like yeah it's not a place to get to I
totally see how people can burn out if
they subject themselves for that to that
for too long so we're trying to stay
really proactive and not get to that
place yeah yeah and I think in terms of
projects for 2020 I don't know if I have
specific project goals we tend to have
we just have like a running list of
ideas of stuff like 100 ideas at this
point I don't know how long the idealist
is and we just kind of like add to it
constantly and pick out ones that were
excited about for upcoming projects
mm-hm
I really just like our excitement level
is what dictates what we do next
yeah I do think we want to play with
doing more series like we started the
diverse DIY series and that's been
really fun like it's kind of fun to have
like a structure and like be able to put
different types of projects within to
that structure and people seem to like
that series and so like we'll continue
that and we might see if there's
something else we can do yeah yeah I
mean that's 2020 coming up yeah are
there any projects you would ever want
to revisit because you're more
experienced with the material now oh by
uncreated automaton that's a very
creative question on I think you're
creative I mean I am general do want to
go back and like revisit old techniques
old project types because the first time
you do something is the hardest and then
we spend all the time figuring things
out getting materials we have like a
closet full of materials right in front
of us I'd love to go back and redo some
project types yeah I think for me it's
not necessarily wanting to go back
because we're alike more experienced
there's just some projects that are
really fun to do but it's hard to
justify going back if you don't like
make it different enough so like the
pendulum painting was so fun like we we
had a lot of requests to do it again
yeah the pendulum yeah yeah so we might
like because we have people submitted we
thought of we thought of we mix it up
yeah
people submitted a bunch of ideas and
then we thought of some additional ideas
so things like that um but it's usually
more because it's like fun and doing it
the first time kind of sparks more
questions that you want answered about
the project like well what if we did
this or what if we did that what it
feels bigger and so usually that's our
motivation for wanting to go back and
redo stuff mm-hmm
yeah I think that we do want to go back
and redo some projects yeah how to help
I got by far the highest voted question
of the entire Q&A Katelyn asked by foxy
Marr how did Katelyn scoff they start
and end
[Laughter]
how did it start
I just remember two started with hot
topic it did well I so I went from like
shopping at American Eagle to shopping
at hot topic like one day we moved I had
wanted to start shopping at a hot topic
because I thought it looked really cool
and I like likes that type of music but
it just felt weird and you know or like
in ninth grade or whatever year I was
when I moved to start doing that to just
all of a sudden started dressing it all
black and with like spikes everywhere
and so I was like well we're moving soon
and when we move I'm just gonna start
shopping a hot topic and then it just
lasted from there until like and then
you started working there and then you
spent all of the money you got from
working there on topic I did it's like
here's your paycheck okay here it is
back all the stuff it'd be my lunch
break and I would just shop I would just
not leave and not eat and I would just
shop and try on clothes and buy things
and I probably like slowed down on the
Hot Topic phase in college mostly
because I got lazy in college and like
in college you start wearing like pj
pants you don't care and like you're
walking to class you don't want to get
sweaty wearing all black both of us are
still wearing pj pants right but yeah
once I start wearing pj pants Gephart do
you ever stop no I just got lazy but I
still like if I walk by a hot topic I
get like good feels good nostalgia
poppin I just like look at stuff and I
still have a few of my outfits like the
spike I have like one of my spiky belt
to have some of my like plaid skirts
with the chains yeah you know just for
nostalgia I have my combat boots yep I
actually have those here they're in like
the costume box just like randomly one
day you're just power carving and then
you're just like wearing those combat
boots cuz I have like all the how old
like
schemes and stuff and it's like a good
accessory for multiple holiday class do
some skit might come up and then you can
be gone kaitlin's oh you could be called
Katelyn those get oh we should make goth
Katelyn a character just so that I have
an excuse to wear my stuff what would
God Evan look like I just can't do the
goth phase like especially like like
Caitlyn has this thing that she used to
like do that she thought was so funny
she's like okay haven't my angry face
that I can do this makes me look like I
smelled something bad yeah what up try
being sad you'd be a really bad cough is
it the pouty five-year-old that's what I
did the laughing goth the Mary goth and
the Mary go Mary go okay this is another
highly voted one where do you get the
blanket on your chair I love it and I
want one I felt this is actually one of
our merch items that prototypes
yeah prototypes so we have this like
you'll see in our channel banner there's
all these little hand-drawn items of
like tools and there's a supervisor yep
like 3d printer Oh cat hair sorry and so
we got a blanket made to like test it
and then we just never I think as a
blanket it was on so we have merged in
two places which is kind of confusing
what we should send everyone to is shop
evident Caitlyn calm which is done by
one fulfillment company but then the
YouTube integrated company that shows up
under the videos is a different company
and that company teespring does the
blankets yeah we what we were trying to
hold off is like oh what can our main
printing company that we do like 99% of
everything do they do blankets and so
that's why I mean is it up there is it
live I think it's up there I thought I
just got it
we have a link I think you can order I
think that on another thing it was just
a little bit on the expensive side
because it's such a big print but I will
send it in the chat right now yeah so
it's there if you want it the next
sponsor video can feature goth okay yeah
we don't see you sponsored parts to do
like as our excuse to do skits yeah yes
I actually had a lot of fun recording
the last skit whoa what was last game
the UM the one we did in front of the
green screen
curiosity stream curiosity stream okay
that was the one that does my wife yeah
and we use all it we use the costume
yeah we use the costume box that was so
much fun I don't know why I have fun
like creating ads there's another chance
to get creative you know included with
the mergers that extra it's it's extra
I'm sorry yeah and this another thing
that we wanted to do is we were worried
about the quality and how it hold up but
it's held up well we got yeah we watched
it a few times we got this about almost
a year ago me yeah and it's still
holding up yeah so let's see are we
planning on doing only dollar store DIYs
like you did Frank that'd be cool we
have if we have a unifying theme if we
have a good enough everyone think of
some kind of theme do you yeah or even a
reoccurring series mm-hmm that'd be even
better
yeah I'm not I think we need to have
like a really good unique new idea yeah
but I think dollar store stuff could be
fun thirty dollars there's two dollar
stores right kind of near us we could
just like pop over there yeah and I
think like things like the IKEA acts or
like a dollar store series are really
fun cuz it's like if you mess it up you
mess it up it's not you didn't put that
much time into it you know and it wasn't
that expensive as opposed to building a
table out of wall nut you know or
something that like or like building a
treadmill desk out of acrylic and resin
and you know where it's like very
expensive and time-consuming material
you know I want to do though I want to
build another wall on that piece of
furniture
- no I fancy every time we like one of
my favorite projects I just don't think
we've posted enough shared about or like
give it enough credit like well we never
throw back to any of our old projects
maybe we should start them at the
entryway walnut table with the finger
joints it looks so good it's held up
it's held up really well I know that
some people have some concerns about
like expansion like it's gonna explode
because of the joinery you did ah but
it's held up really well it's like all
of the edges are still perfect
everything is still just like mmm it's
so good it's just a beautiful piece of
furniture like really brings me a lot of
joy so I think we maybe we need to bring
back wall now at some point I want to do
walnut and brass oh yeah I really want
to combine brass and walnut we did that
once really long time ago on the frame
that's it's in our master oh yeah with a
screw thing yeah yeah what's the biggest
risk you've taken and what's the biggest
risk you plan on taking the biggest risk
we've taken you tube channel no no the
biggest risk I think I personally have
taken is just quitting my job cuz I was
fed up with it
and I didn't know what I was gonna do
next I'm not sure how much I've told of
that story I think we haven't really
actually because like so like everyone
we like announced when we quit our jobs
because like YouTube was promising
enough that we could see it becoming
like a full-time thing like that was on
the horizon and so we quit our jobs but
what people don't know is before we
started the channel was the first time
you quit your job yeah no plans for
anything we might have touched on it on
an earlier podcast but I can't keep
track of it anymore she's gonna hear it
again if you've already heard the story
I was working a job it was pretty
all-consuming I was leading a law like a
small team and I was in charge of a lot
I was wearing a lot of hats I was the IT
I was product development I was the
manufacturing coordinator that I did all
of the engineering approvals for all of
the drawings I coordinated
the small team it was just like a lot on
my plate and I worked long hours and
when I came home odd eat and would like
watch the show or something maybe your
go to bed but I could eat it like 8:00
or 9:00 or 9:30 or 10:00 and after after
eating I just didn't have any energy cuz
I was worn out from a long day and I
knew I wanted to change I just didn't
know what it was and I couldn't really
think oh I didn't have enough time and
energy to dedicate towards it so Kalin
trusted me she said having just yeah you
feel like you can figure that out just
go for it and I was like I just want to
quit I'm done so I just did it
Caitlin kept her job her day job and she
like could guarantee that we will be
totally fine because we have no kids low
expenses we're you know we bought we
bought a very reasonable house that was
well within our means we had savings so
I just quit and I didn't have much of a
plan I lucked into consulting pretty
early on and helped supplement our
income there but then I just figured it
out and that's when we started the West
End that's when we started you know
selling our 3d printer products I
applied to a whole bunch of different
jobs but creating our own ended up being
the right fit for us yeah it's not the
right fit for everyone it definitely
isn't
but it's the right fit for us yeah so
that was the biggest risk I've taken
what about you jumping out of an
airplane um yeah I don't know I mean I
guess risk was dating your friend oh
yeah oh that was probably Fred that was
probably one of the biggest risks Jim
Carrey referring to each other yes we
were friends for like five years before
we started dating he and I were like
really like long-term friends sometimes
would like go a while without chatting
too much or seeing each other it's not
like we hung out every day but like we
were the type of friend
that like and some semesters we did when
we have classes together yeah but
weirdness the type of friends read this
knew that you were going to be friends
with that person for the rest of your
life because you just got along so well
you're on the same page with each other
you have the same interests it's like a
lot of our friends were like how did you
not see this before we had one of
Kalin's friends like the first time we
hung out with Caleb just like you guys
should get married or something yeah
and Kalyn was like now his friends but
we were really good friends for five
years and deciding to start dating each
other and convert that friendship into a
relationship that was a big risk because
this yeah what if like if it hadn't have
worked out then that would have been
awkward so I think before we even
started moving into like a relationship
phase we sat down and we talked about
like what do you want in the future what
do you think about work-life balance
what do you think about like all the
things we're like hey look I want to
tell you all of the embarrassing stories
that you might hear in the future let's
get all of that out of the way so that
all the important stuff that like could
be relationship like deal-breakers down
the line yeah
so we're like okay before before we
commit down this path let's yeah it's
like make sure like there aren't any
stumbling block there's not gonna be any
stumbling BOTS yeah yeah that probably
is like one of the riskiest things
that's definitely the riskiest thing
yeah definitely more risky than jumping
out of the airplane nothing more risky
than jumping out of airplanes we had
professionals strapped to our backs
funny yeah because there's like a weight
limit for the combined two people when
you're skydiving and Evans a bigger
person you have like the smallest guy
attached to zach so if you stood up all
the way you would have lifted funny big
picture man I wanted to do it but I felt
awkward like at the thought of maybe
doing that
ha comment how do we come up with our
skits from Chris 93 I think so
sometimes the skits are like a bass
drowned a sponsor so there's a little
bit of requirements of like okay we have
to relate it somehow but we started
doing skits not for a sponsors just as
like intros and we really like the like
infomercial style so that's what we
started with originally was like
infomercial style skits and we just kind
of came up with what we thought would be
funny the very first one we did was in
the dust collection cart those are very
first implemented I'll skip this because
we wanted to make it more fun for you
guys dust collection card that soap
that's like such a boring thing to build
like how do we make it more fun so start
it out of a necessity or like a desire
to make it more fun and that's just our
style of humor that's just like I mean
you guys know you've seen their videos
it's all lame lame jokes
lots of puns like every now and then the
the tiniest pinch of innuendo you know
it's like a little sprinkles
yeah but uh you know this is a very
natural fit for us yeah um how was your
Thanksgiving gee Jeannie Black Friday
shopping
I think skipping was delicious it was so
good like double Thanksgiving cuz we had
Thanksgiving at your family and in my
family's we got to like combine
delicious items those had it a couple
times more it was great yeah and like
sometimes after Thanksgiving you don't
necessarily want to have Thanksgiving
again but we have Thanksgiving four
times yeah delicious every time and we
probably a particularly awesome
Thanksgiving on both friends like both
families like we and our families are
really really good cooks yeah so it's
like always good but it was like
particularly tough it was particularly
delicious yeah Brussels sprouts oh my
god I'm nervous and I like Brussels
sprouts but I think that another aspect
of
the the things giving leftovers that we
have mastered is we have gotten a little
bit better about reheating meat which is
always hard to reheat it's always like
sometimes the texture changes or like
something about it changes the the
secret is to be unhealthy just like
every other cooking thing to make it
better doesn't make it more unhealthy
and you know the secret is butter butter
we do is you create like a little foil
pouch this is what we did for the turkey
but we've done it with like other
leftover meat type stuff before you
create a foil pouch you put a bunch of
butter on top of the turkey or whatever
your heating close the pouch and put it
in the oven and it like keeps it really
moist and then the butter is like
absorbed wheeze the left butter from oh
my god calls us just in general sorry
this is so tasty tasty yeah so it
prevents it from drying out cause you
don't want dried out meats we didn't
really do any Black Friday shopping we
did happen to like do some Christmas
shopping on Amazon like I think which
might have been on Black Friday but I
don't know if any if we like got any
deals or anything we just happen to be
like oh yeah we should do some Christmas
shopping and it just happened to be
ready yeah and we didn't do any sales on
our own store just because right now the
profit margins on our merch is like how
much because we do print on demand so
it's like it's a little it's a lot more
a little it's a lot more expensive than
doing like buying shirts in bulk and
keeping stock and so the profit margins
are a lot smaller so it's instead of
doing sales we just keep it at that
lower level because otherwise I mean it
would just be ridiculous to have like
t-shirts that are like 35 40 dollars at
some point in the future we probably
will move to another merch thing but I
think still for now even at our size and
the sales that we have going on we want
to keep it print on demand because
Caitlyn is prototyping three different
shirt designs like right now different
things we need to order samples we need
to get them in see how they wear test it
out and it's it's a little bit of a
process but when we launch it we can
launch it in men's in women's in kid
so many different colors all different
colors like for excel or extra small
yeah so it's like the breadth of what we
can offer is ridiculous
and there are some pain points in
general but I think that long-term will
well no I don't think we're ever gonna
stop making numerous new designs but I
think that we might stabilize at some
point in the future yeah and then we can
maybe move to or you know maybe we could
do a mix maybe we can have all of our
print-on-demand stuff that is have some
that we keep a stock of that we can
offer at a lower price and we have it
fulfilled by logistical issues yeah
what's your proudest moment
foxy Mara proudest moment I think for me
it kind of goes back to making this
company work yeah making evident Katelyn
a viable career for the two of us yeah
so there's it's hard to like put that on
a specific moment yeah cuz it's a lot of
stuff just gradually changing it wasn't
like there was it's not like one day we
were not a financially viable business
and then one day we were or like one day
we didn't we couldn't see where the
channel was going and then one day we
could yeah I think that when we were
starting out we thought like okay maybe
when we pass 100,000 subscribers that'll
be the moment we're like we consider
it's a success but like then we realize
it's not really tied to it's not about
like what how many subs you have there
was a combination of how many views you
get per video how many sponsors you have
the relationships you have on all these
things that's how well set up is your
back-end and everything can you keep
doing what you're doing long-term you
know because you can't like be super
successful for six months and then burn
out you know yeah and also like the
longer we do this the more committed we
are to like do this forever
in some ways it's like if we do this for
five years by that point I'm just not
gonna want to do anything else I'm just
like I already don't
want to do yeah I've been like two and a
half years a little bit more and I'm
already like no this is this dead yes
content creation this is yes the rest of
our career yeah so I think the proudest
moment wasn't exactly a moment but
looking back at you know my life the
thing one of the things I'm most proud
of is creating this company with you
that is so well suited to the two of us
that we both like fully share and we're
fully invested in because one thing I
don't know if we've talked about this
much either but there were growing pains
when we were figuring out what we were
doing you know like both of us had
things that we weren't sure about we're
like what's the with the message the
scope the internal goal of external
facing goals what's like the the mission
statement internally and externally what
types of projects do we want to do
long-term what type of impact do we want
to have all of that will stuff that we
had to figure out slowly over time and I
feel like we've got a really good place
there and and that just happened slowly
iterating again and again and again per
video experimenting and talking a lot
between the two of us a lot of walks a
lot of walks figured out everything how
does it feel knowing you inspire so many
people - now follow they're making
dreams from anxious emoji oh very sweet
of you to say it's yeah it's it's it is
kind of crazy thinking about the number
of people that see our videos and it's a
really cool feeling and at the same time
it's also hard to like like picture that
amount of people not that everyone who
watches is like immediately gonna start
making stuff or anything and we know a
lot of people in our audience just watch
for fun it's not necessarily to make
things but I do think it's a really cool
feeling like sometimes people will send
like you know tweet photos or post on
Instagram photos of projects they've
made based on our videos and we're like
you know um so yeah just like it just
gives
the good feels seeing other people like
not being afraid to try something
because they saw us try it and it's like
okay if they can do that then I can do
it do you know yeah it's something that
we take seriously but we also try not to
let it burden us Brett enough
yeah like the responsibility the
responsibility it's like you know kind
of like Jenna she kind of does what she
wants she but she's also respectful of
people's time and you know trying to do
things the best that she can and
everything she wants about a good
content and everything and I think that
we kind of feel similar issue we want to
feel the freedom to do our own things
and the things that are exciting to us
because that's what we need to keep us
going long-term but we also feel like a
little bit of the responsibility of
putting out good content I'm not sure
it's a hard feeling it's a hard internal
feeling to express but it's something
that we feel lucky for and we also take
seriously I don't know if that makes
sense
faking it for half a second I think
words are hard yeah I think um I think
what you're saying is maybe like this is
something that I know a lot of other
maker channels try to balance like how
do i balance doing stuff that other
people could realistically do versus
stuff that I just want to do that seems
fun and so in that regard we do try to
mix it up sometimes and like sometimes
we'll do
akia hacks which are like you know very
beginner friendly projects that a lot of
people can do like in a video like that
we see a ton of comments like oh I'm
gonna get that lamp today and I'm gonna
do it or I'm gonna try that on some
candles and then there are some projects
we do that we know like are not really
practical
thanks a million layer clay yeah or even
like the the treadmill desks like in the
way that we did it
nothing a treadmill desk isn't practical
you could totally build that but the way
we did it doing like a giant resin pour
and this
that like it's not it's not really like
the most practical for most people to do
but we just really wanted to so there is
a little balance of balancing like what
other people might realistically want to
tackle and be inspired to realistically
tackle but we hope that also even we do
so that's not super realistic it might
like spark some ideas
um so even if you're not gonna make that
exact thing
it might make you know a process seem
less intimidating or whatever you know
yeah oh this is this is a really
interesting one Aggie rock-and-roll asks
if you're gonna have a domesticated
fantasy creature what would it be
that's a really hard one because so many
things run through my head one a Pikachu
Pikachu cuz they're so friendly and like
like like grabs like a little Pikachu
like snuggling like on the couch with us
or like sleeping on the bed with us or
something like that oh that's such a
good answer
so Pikachu would be one so it's not best
on the cuteness perspective a fantasy
creature what about an incredibly
advanced artificial intelligence that
would link into all of our computers
help us with editing line up the audio
could be a creature that's but you're
saying this is like a fantasy creature
that you've domesticated okay a fantasy
creature how about this a spirit of
technology that floated around hey
listen you have five notifications the
spirit of technology could edit for you
could like hey hey spirit of technology
can you go ahead and import all of the
footage from all of the cameras pull
them into an Adobe file line them all up
and sync all the audio and create all
the audio issues and I could just like
do that because it's the spirit of
technology that'd be nice to have I
still feel like it's a stretch to the
original question and then the know it's
a fantasy creature it's a creature and
it's fantastical I don't know if like it
counts as a creature you don't
experience or creatures oh I thought it
was artificial intelligence I don't know
it wasn't artists it to a spirit I
changed this year
still think it's a stretchy Chavo Chavo
let me know is this is this within the
rules I would like I would I do agree
with Pikachu you know what else I want
what Totoro Totoro
oh yeah that's on a big be awesome where
it is sleep in the trees outside yeah
we'd have like a lot of land okay you
know this is on our maker farm yeah it
could yeah it could hang out outside but
we'd also have like a full garage door
like giant entrance that you could come
inside and just like hang out and then
we go lay on his belly and watch movies
I think it sounds great so we have some
people saying it's okay a lot of people
saying it's a stretch okay so it looks
like a little bit of a stretch and
that's how you get how oh yeah okay so
it's a mixed it's a mixed reaction there
to how stretched like this sir Queen oh
thanks for gifting a sub to foxy morrow
that's awesome thank you see you can
change any one thing about YouTube what
do you change the foxy mark coming in
with some hot questions how about this
YouTube is dealing with a very difficult
situation we we didn't watch all of it
but Susan Wojcicki just did a 60 Minutes
interview about YouTube about the back
end about like everything that's going
on there and they are facing a lot of
issues I think that they hired 10,000
police just to review content and I
think that someone did the calculation
of what that would be if they paid them
all like minimum wage what that yearly
cost of that I think it was like 50
million dollars per year or something
like that just to review content four
hundred million dollars four hundred
million dollars whoo yeah that's a lot
of money trying to fix some of the
issues that YouTube is facing
I'm not saying that they're doing a
perfect job of it because it's a tough
situation but I think that one thing
that I would appreciate as a content
creator is maybe a little more data a
little bit more feedback from YouTube
detailed statistics song like why
something maybe got surpassed or what is
going on and I know that could lead to
some people reverse engineering the
algorithm but then just make the
algorithm even better I'm not sure I
know that I'm just like throwing your
answers out there but the answer really
still is YouTube is the only platform
doing what it's doing and it's
empowering a lot of people to reach
their audiences to form niche
communities to come together around a
whole bunch of issues is it perfect no
can it be perfect
anything could be perfect
now what competitors be good yes yeah I
think competitors would be good but like
this there's no one out there Facebook
come on get on that like Facebook's
attempts haven't been great from what
I've seen it's just just kind of bad
Amazon kind of somewhat sort of has like
you can upload videos but it's like this
like in this like TV series type weird
back an interface no one can find it no
one can search it like Amazon has the
hosting power the computing power but
it's just not the community is not there
that yeah SEO isn't there the website
isn't there it's just yeah so if we
could change one thing about YouTube I
think more transparency more
transparency would be good and I know
that like there are issues there that
they need to resolve so maybe maybe
they're working on that I'm not sure but
uh that's that's maybe something for
more software engineers to answer
because a lot of YouTube is just a lot
of software engineering
because YouTube tries to YouTube really
has to maintain as much of an impartial
hand as possible that's why they need to
rely on algorithms because then they can
say hey we're not making any judgments
it's the algorithm but then that creates
its own problem so yeah no no okay quick
question um I've seen this one up to
here for a while so I wanted to get it
can you update your website with all the
new streaming equipment or make a
patreon video about it from 7:00 I am
Brooke um I think we have if you go to
our amazon.com cast or gaming videos we
have a link it's like an Amazon link
where we have a link to like our Amazon
store that has all of our streaming
stuff we can post it here too yeah I
think that this has yeah pretty much all
of what we do
yeah but it's also in any podcast or
gaming video on youtube you can find
link yeah well post it and I know that
we we also have a link on our website
under tools that might be out of date
hard to keep everything organized
everywhere you know what's the first
piece of furniture we ever made by
Cynthia B French does the love letters
count as a piece of furniture I don't
think that's I think the first furniture
is that are 2x4 side table no no no it
was the for the other side table oh the
one that we didn't make a video about
yeah oh that sucked
it was just like upside down you made
out of one by material we got kind of
fancy you did dowels
how did dowel joints but it was very
wobbly was very wobbly yeah we like just
got some pine stained it we didn't do
the best joints we didn't do and there
was like a little crossbar support a
little shelf okay okay okay
and then we made like I somehow like
less pretty bench I wanted to make out
of aluminum and I made out of aluminum
and like stained two by fours well
because we wanted
to be an outdoor bench because weed
people coming over and not enough
outdoor chair so we were like who's make
a bench real quick and so we made it
with aluminum legs and then like treated
outdoor lumber it was really ugly really
I mean your mom has it now is like a
outdoor plant stand yeah it's all
aluminum stainless steel it's all
treated lumber aluminum and stainless
steel so it's like good materials just
not the best design sense that's when I
was more on the functional side of
things instead of the practical yeah
yeah if you could only use one color for
all your future projects what do you
chose brown so we can use wood oh that's
pretty good yeah that is not a car I
think that works yeah cuz wood comes in
lots of shades of brown because it's
like I could pick a color and then
everything resin is that color this
brown resin oh no I was thinking like
blue because blue you could do like the
ocean resin mm-hmm usually different
shades of blue for like geode stuff or
you could do like darker blues for
galaxy well so if it's one color for all
of your future projects does that mean
that we can't use wood yes brown brown
brown and all of its shades like dark
brown light brown
Julie Browns Browns in general I thought
Evan would say it's hard to beat we'd
need a lot of brass to make everything
gold yeah what was your favorite past
project
[Music]
I think that that's too broad of a
question it's kind of like what's your
favorite movie it's like what's your
answer like what's your favorite like
practical and what's your favorite not
practical I have even more caveat so
it's like when you're saying what's your
favorite movie is it comedy is an action
is it whatever you know but like when it
comes to what's your favorite past
project is it in terms of the filming
what the edit turned out like or the
project it's not the project is
something you pick one of those things
okay my favorite one to film was the
Halloween ghosts that was so fun is one
of our least watched videos but the
process of creating that video was so
fun it was so freeform very there's no
pain points to it at all
yeah it was just like such and and we
had fun filming it and we we did that
little like nice thing that yeah
Halloween's behind us with the color
wall and everything and you you you
filmed the things at night and the
blowing in the wind and stuff I mean
there are lots of ones that were fun to
film
I enjoyed the alcoholic project a lot
alcohol ink project I enjoyed that a lot
but the ghost was just so fun zero pain
points I feel like I'm like in the back
of my head still searching for an idea
that would be like so fun practical easy
entertaining all these things all of
these like magic sauce ingredients to a
good project I'd say one of my favorite
projects in terms of just like well
mostly in terms of the process but I
also really like how it turned out was
the resin geode slices it's the first
time we like really tried resin art and
it was just so magical and there like
wasn't anything that really went wrong
you know it was pretty chill and it was
just like I'm like we're making new
things that actually look like J oh my
god so that was those are really fun one
I almost like want to do that again but
that would be hard to mix up I think max
we have
we do have an idea on how to do it again
but mix it up I also tend to enjoy the
weapon videos so like the propane cannon
and once we there's like a test a
demonstration at the end I think yeah I
like shooting stuff or destroying things
so like the propane cannon and like the
zombie weapon the flail the nail flail
are really fun but it's cuz you get to
like get out the slow-mo camera and like
blow up some fruit and like various
stuff so that's was fun yeah let's see
what was the biggest unanticipated
challenge in running a channel
unanticipated challenge I think a lot of
the challenges we knew were coming so I
don't know if they count as
unanticipated the biggest unanticipated
challenge of running a channel I think
because we did so much research we kind
of expected all of the things we ran
into yeah I think because like when we
started our channel there's a lot of
people already doing YouTube as their
full-time jobs a lot of people who we'd
like talked to you know not just not
just observed from the outside so we
knew that it would be a lot of work we
knew that like you know running your own
business is hard from like like tax
perspective and stuff like that um I
think from my perspective after thinking
about it probably for the first time in
a long time the biggest unanticipated
challenge of running the channel is
knowing what your goal and identity is
because that's something that we are
like we kept on thinking that we have
found it right oh hey now we know weirdo
okay now we know what we're doing and I
think it only settled in towards the
beginning of this year 2019 and that was
after almost two years of doing it yeah
so it took us two years to figure out
what we were doing
in terms of like what types of content
we want and to make even though from the
outside it might not seem like we varied
that much I mean we're still doing
project videos but um yeah it took us
that long to like kind of nail down our
style and even even then before we even
started the channel we thought long long
long and hard about what type of channel
we wanted to do what site and type of
precedent we wanted to set because once
you start making videos you're setting a
precedent and you will either disappoint
or happily surprise people depending on
how you shift how you move how you keep
on going and so setting the right
expectations setting up a future-proof
path for yourself going forward with
like the type of content your style your
your humor your personality everything
you kind of need to figure so much of
that out and we thought that we had done
a lot of that but we didn't and I think
that's the most unanticipated part yeah
how much continued brainstorming went
into it after we launched yeah yeah cool
ok time management rut got up no we knew
that that was gonna be hard oh yeah and
also both of us are pretty good at time
management
we both love lists we have we got so
many lists and it's all so organized we
have all of our tattoos in one place we
have all of our project management and
the other invoicing tracking everything
all organized and everything is linked
between our two like computers and
everything so time management we got we
just don't have much time yeah though we
but we knew that we wouldn't have much
time
yeah like we warned all of our friends
and family before we started the channel
like hey hang out as much yeah so it was
expected due to their uh kill well kill
I because or maybe will says you to do
everything together do you ever feel
like you need a break from money from
one another no no but it might not be
the same for everyone we started this
because we wanted more time together
like we
wanted to spend all of our time together
so the only time where I think that
we're not happy with the balance of our
time together is when the two of us are
doing the separate things like we're
like we've been next to each other for a
long part of the day we've been together
but I feel like I haven't seen you much
today yeah so that's the only time where
I feel like the balance isn't right I
know that that seems corny
we are corny yeah welcome yeah yeah yeah
we don't really want to spend more time
apart even when we're doing like
non-business stuff we prefer to do it
together and in terms of like what being
together does for us it makes the winds
of our channel so much better we can
share it we can we know everything that
went into it literally everything we've
both been there for everything we help
each other out on everything when we're
sending important emails I always type
it up and then let Caitlin review it and
send it and vice versa and we review
business contracts together we are
involved with everything together like
everything about Evan and Caitlin is
evident Caitlin like but also like when
there's something difficult weekend
share that and it's not just like a bird
and only on one person you know so it
makes like the goods better and it makes
the like struggles not as bad yeah we
don't feel bad bringing up the same
thing that's bothering us again and
again and again until it's resolved
because we're both affected by this
thing yeah so it works out really well
yeah corny and proud we have brought the
corn the corn here's the coin welcome
welcome
yeah yeah I know we like hanging out we
like it a lot
do you worry about video length much we
used to a little bit we used to kind of
like worry that like oh no our videos
kind of long in this day is that is that
gonna bother people or whatever and now
we're like hey it is what it is we cut
out anything that wasn't good
and what's left is what we feel proud of
yeah the interesting thing I will say
because we used to worry like if a video
was too long mmm that was like a bigger
YouTube mentality and because we started
out doing more like tutorials people
don't necessarily want a tutorial to be
longer because that makes it seem like
it's more complicated yeah you know then
as we started moving towards
entertainment the links didn't bother us
as much but I will say like I think the
last short video we did was earlier this
year are like painting our closet doors
yeah like the um that video I think was
like eight or nine minutes and like it's
that seems so short to me now and that
wasn't even that long ago um but I think
like I do feel like I would feel a
little guilty doing too many short under
10 minutes like short video but now it
feels weird to do short yeah most videos
were like 6 minutes all of them were
under 10 time and this has nothing to do
with the whole like oh 10 minutes you
put another ad at the end it's just our
average now is like 15 to 25 minutes and
it feels weird doing significantly less
than that you know I'm just using the
IKEA project as an example and I know we
brought it up at the end of the video
but our original idea for that was like
oh we'll just get some frames do the
alcohol art and set it on fire
but then I was like oh it's if there's
not enough there and that could have
been okay we did an abstract one will
try for like a more drawing one we'll
try a few different techniques we'll try
it fire not fire but like it just didn't
seem like enough yeah so we do worry
about it not being like enough and
that's kind of more tied to like like
what we're doing then how long that
takes but it's related to how long it
takes you know so that's like an odd
switch yeah we were worried about it
being too long and then we're worried
about it being too short yeah it's gonna
be what its gonna be we don't we won't
like ever pad a video because we feel
like it's too short or cut down too much
because we feel like it's too long think
about longest video is about soap 44
pieces of soap or how many was I think
there
seven pieces of soap and it was at 41
minute long wait a few minutes for soap
don't be what's called - yeah sorry I
think that when we think about the time
of a video it's more about the scope
once we're filming and editing it
doesn't really answer our mind at all
would you rather have a cat with a human
face or a cat with human hands a cat
with human hands cat with human hands
it'd be amazing
like if the supervisor could help us in
the shop you know like hey can you hold
this
can you yeah maybe stop opening doors
actually that might be terrible why
don't you pick things up if you'd like
opposable fingers and she could like
pick things up and cause human yeah
that'd be weird
puppy do weird that'd be too weird okay
so maybe like a monkey got a face that's
just out by default yeah a monkey cat
it'd be like a monkey cat no but monkey
faces aren't human faces no no no a cat
with like human hands would look kind of
like a monkey cat yeah yeah yeah well
but also so I was human hand would you
like large human hands that's I was
picturing does it scale I was thinking
that it's scale that the kind of work
that like cat sized but human shapes
human shapes like furry - I'd be kind of
awesome that I can think of an awesome
jungle gym for ya but you definitely not
a human face Thank You knife Roxas for
the disturbing did you know what you
what you wanted to make videos about
before we started or did it evolve
organically we generally knew we wanted
to videos about like making things and
fixing up our house cuz we had started a
blog that was like fixing up our house
and when we bought it and like making
stuff for our wedding because we like
DIY it everything for our wedding and so
it seemed like the natural progression
so we didn't really like consider other
channel options really
but the thing that evolved is like the
balance between making stuff and just
being kind of like more entertainment
based because we used to do a lot more
instruction so that's so like allowing
ourselves to just squash clay and make
pots out of them yeah like doing stuff
that's not practical that wasn't
something we really did right beginning
we want to maybe I'm not sure how or
when or what genre or what shape it's
gonna take but we want to do just like
fun experiments and if any experiments
around making and then maybe we'll do
something practical at the end or maybe
it'll just be the experiment but I think
that we want to do more science adjacent
with heaven indicate on type videos yeah
in the future okay I think we should
pick like a couple more questions mr.
Nicholas post longest it's gonna be a
long one for me at it yeah I'll just
leave everything in sorry all those
pauses and whatever okay
biggest thing you're looking forward to
in 2023 audience with that one
kind of yeah I just having a better
work-life balance yeah nothing really
like external just internal stuff what
was the best we've ever received
Caitlin's coffeemakers is one of them
was a really good gift it's it's are
currently most use gift no the best gift
I think are the like experience type
gifts oh so like like sometimes we'll
get a gift that's like like stay at this
cool bed-and-breakfast like for a
weekend yeah and that's like like
there's no other presents it's just like
that's the one gift and that's kind of
like my favorite gift what do you think
about my misspelled birthday present I
mean that was my favorite gift no that
was an anniversary gift merci but it
still is a gift yeah I miss Felidae
gifts for our anniversary
you're welcome
there's a video of that on our second
channel by the way if you don't know
we're talking about okay have you found
the item for the next by verse DIY we do
have a couple contenders we do I don't
know if they're gonna be the next one
they will be I think they are pushing it
a little bit on the envelope of
practicality one involves a but it's
pretty hilarious like when we saw this
we just knew we had to get it and make a
video about it it's just this is so good
yeah that's all we can say another one
is another light another one is another
light and we don't want to do like too
many like light related we've only done
two BIOS DIYs and one was like one was
lights I want kind wanna get some
variety we're kind of thinking about
like the first few things in the series
kind of defined to the scope of it in
some ways so I kind of want to like keep
on pushing it before we do a repeat type
item we do have a few which is the
second channel oh yeah we do Caitlin -
yeah see what do you do in your lack of
freedom ha ha ha nice King well now we
re gonna walk and every now and then
will like what organize the house well
organize the house sometimes yeah yeah
yeah that's that's all we have time I
mean putting like that it seems kind of
sad but we really do enjoy what we're
doing but we would like to do oh yeah we
see family yeah we see family look for
dinner and stuff every now on them yeah
we go out for meals yeah that's it
that's the extent of the time that we
have yeah is filming creative shots or
editing quality content more challenging
by mr. harvoy I'm not sure what that
mean I think um I think the editing is
more challenging but I might be biased
because like usually if we're doing a
more creative shot that's more on Evan
and if we're doing editing that's more
on me I do love stop-motion
yeah when I think of like with the
stop-motions or I think of when we do
like half the screen is in fact yeah the
other halves not but I
it's the thing overall editing is like
just takes up so much more time than
setting up the creative shots yeah thank
you and guess what oh it's time for
thing of the week it's time for thing of
the week our saying of the week this
time is 2019 YouTube rewind JK yeah yeah
a funny troll thing to say cuz it was
really boring it was so boring
I saw I saw some like like you know I
saw some promotional stuff for saying
we're gonna try something different we
heard you guys last year is the most
disliked thing we're mixing it up and
doing something different it was
different it was also just really it was
really boring this is like wait it's a
yeah I feel like it was um
I mean understandably they took less
risks like put less reasons and
therefore people to meet mad at them it
was just like we honestly we didn't even
watch the whole thing we got bored yeah
we at first I thought like okay are they
gonna change out of the like top-10
format and nope no it was like nothing
original nothing creative is very bland
and just kind of you know I think that
was interesting what they try to do with
some international creators some
breakout creators some parts of that
there's like some good intent behind
some aspects of it yeah but it did
reflect like what actually I mean not
that I like verified the numbers but you
know what it seemed to show is that it
was reflecting based on actual data but
you know another thing they could have
done if they wanted to take the same
approach keep it kind of very very safe
and just do like here are the most like
things here the most viewed things
here's this they could have remixed it
all with like a song and like kind of
like there's this DJ out there called DJ
earworm and I think that he does like he
takes all of the music that was popular
that year and there's a mix of them all
where they merge together
and that's a lot harder to do because
like not all the videos were music like
you can do that with music you know but
what I think they should have done is I
think they should have liked like all
the creators and stuff they highlighted
based on the numbers you know like I
think that was pretty cool but they
should have then taken those creators
and created something original yeah
with it and I know that that's like a
lot of budget and they had the risk of
just being totally roasted again and
spending a lot of money and taking up a
lot of creators time just till I get
roasted again it's kind of risky but
they could have even done like it in
between I had like some of the creators
film like reaction stuff yeah you know
or I don't know something I know easier
in low budget and like it didn't have to
be anything crazy oh my gosh Oh Jan says
right now it has 2.3 million likes but
5.3 million dislikes you know yeah are
there any comments that aren't the copy
and paste comment oh yeah what was up
with the oil guys check out the comment
section it's like an organic meme that
just happened yeah I'm like is it a meme
I don't understand I think it means that
has happened just in that videos just
for that video just organically there
someone did it and it just caught on and
it's insane yeah that's crazy yeah
anyway it's a week honestly we didn't
really have enough time to prepare for
this podcast we thought would have all
the time remember like oh but anyway we
just thought it'd be funny to rag on
that YouTube rewind
even though I understand already that
they I understand why they did this yeah
alright guys well thanks so much for
tuning in if you're tuning in live
appreciate that thanks for listening
very long podcast I hope that we
answered some questions you might have
had if not we'll do more of these in the
future we do want to make the live the
live podcast like recurring in some
capacity yeah and we'll keep on mixing
up the time so people from different
time zones can join in and stuff like
that also cuz we don't have a schedule
but I hope you're having a great day
and we'll look forward to talking at you
now
by I probably know after stream today
guys the whole thing was basically an
after stream funny work ahead out and uh
the next dream will be video games again
so we'll look forward to seeing you
craft
yeah probably minecraft
[Music]